step one manifesting according to
science you gotta claim what you want
and tell the truth so let's say that
step one I want to train for and I want
to complete the New York City marathon
that is a bucket list item for me and in
fact that was a bucket list item for me
and it's something that I've done and
you should do it too it's amazing and so
yes you're gonna wake up every day and
you're gonna write that dream down but
to achieve it please do not spend any
time visualizing crossing the Finish
Line please do not spend any time
thinking about the Roaring Applause of
the crowd as your name gets announced
instead what are you gonna do you're
gonna use science you're gonna visualize
yourself lacing up your running shoes
when it's 10 degrees outside you're
going to close your eyes and you're
going to picture what it feels like to
be out there on a training run alone
it's mile 13 you're on your own and
you're freaking earbuds just ran out of
batteries and you're six miles from your
house and as you close your eyes and you
picture that annoying and irritating
moment I want you to feel in your body
the sin station of that moment hey it's
Evan Carl Michael and I make these
videos because of my first business I
struggled to stay afloat I quit my
business partner and the thing that kept
me going was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn some practical
steps to reprogram your mind enjoy
it's 5 A.M
your alarm goes off
you're exhausted
you look out the window
and you see it's pouring rain
and it's a Saturday
and you said you do a training run
and I want you to see yourself
dragging yourself out of bed you're
pulling on your jacket even though you
don't feel like it and walking out that
door and I want you to feel yourself
starting to run in the rain and it's 5
10 in the morning
that's how you manifest
because here's the thing
that's what you're going to have to do
in order
to achieve your goal
and more importantly
five months from now
when you've registered for that race
and that alarm goes off at 5am and you
roll over in real life and you look out
the window and it's pouring you will
have rehearsed this moment
so your brain and your nervous system
and your body is going to be ready for
it you're going to roll out of bed
because you've already been in this
moment you already have seen yourself
there you've already felt the resistance
you not only know exactly how this goes
you've rehearsed it in your mind and
you've now rewired your brain to be
ready for it
that's why you can't half-ass this you
got to be dead serious about visualizing
the steps you need to take
and so now that you got step one which
is tell the truth about what you want
get very clear about it step two is stop
focusing on the end and start focusing
on the irritating crap you're going to
have to do day in day out to March
toward it now we're going to go from the
kindergarten manifesting according to
Neuroscience to Olympic level
manifesting are you ready I'm ready
because step three to properly manifest
according to science you got to feel
that stuff in your body I mean really
feel it you gotta feel what it's like
to work for that dream now this isn't
just Mel Robbins and this is not even
neuroscientists anymore we're now
bringing in the Olympic athletes and all
of their team of psychologists because
they take manifesting to an even deeper
level
when you're on the Olympic team
you call this imagery
because it goes Way Beyond sort of the
visualization an Olympic aerial skier
said you have to smell it you have to
hear it you have to feel it you have to
feel everything
and so that means as you are closing
your eyes and as you are visualizing
yourself doing the work and for an
Olympic skier that means before you even
get on that slope
you are imagining every twist every turn
every bump every jump you are going over
and over and over and over again every
twist and every turn now let's get to
step four
because this is probably the most
important part of manifesting according
to neuroscience
and I think absolutely everybody forgets
to tell you this part you have to do the
thing you're visualizing when you sit
there and you intentionally mentally
rehearse the steps you need to take
there is something that you owe the
universe and you owe yourself and that
is to take the action
you're not just going to sit there and
train at some point that Olympic athlete
has to do the race at some point you've
got to make the cold call at some point
you've got to quit the job or pack the
U-Haul trailer or get off your ass and
do the training run at 5am so you better
believe there is going to be something
that is asked of you in return and
that's where the magic comes in because
the magic is in your actions and
manifesting according to Neuroscience
just gets your own fears and people's
judgments and your childhood wiring out
of the way so that you can take those
actions true science-backed manification
it's not as sexy as the secret makes it
seem and it's actually not as
complicated as a huge PhD study makes it
seem
you just have to do it that's it you
have to take the actions
you do owe the universe and yourself
something you owe yourself the actions
the effort the work that's required
that's what your dreams demand I talk
about this all the time you know we all
want to believe that somehow you're
going to close your eyes and imagine
what you want it's going to magically
happen I'm sorry that may happen on Tick
Tock or in Disney but that is not how
the real world works
the way that you are going to make
something a reality is you are going to
declare that you want it and then you
are going to tediously annoyingly wake
up every single day and push yourself to
lay one brick
in a path
with one action
every day
it's not going to be easy but day by day
week by week month by month year by year
action by action as you visualize
yourself taking the steps and then you
actually push yourself to do the steps
you will wake up and realize you have
paved a brick path to your dreams and
you are now Ten Years Later five years
later sitting on the porch of your Ocean
House you are crossing the finish line
of the New York City marathon you are
making the final turn in that giant
slalom race
that is how this works rule number two
is Manifest your dreams with Dr swart
once I discovered neuroplasticity I
thought I wish I'd known about this when
I was 18. really you know it's literally
life-changing I think I was naturally
manifesting from about the age of 18
anyway but I didn't understand the
science behind it once you understand
that you can literally change your brain
at any stage any age any mindset
that's like
it's life-changing isn't it and and I
feel that you know one of the things we
were sort of chatting about earlier is
that just because I'm a scientist and an
MD it doesn't mean that in my real life
it's easy for me to just Channel
neuroplasticity it's still it's still
hard you know I've been through a
divorce I've been through grief I've
been through career change
and
those Hard Times taught me resilience
and neuroplasticity
but the hard times were almost the
opportunity I didn't want to go through
those things I don't want you know our
listeners to go through hard times yeah
pain but
you can take that as an opportunity and
I think if you really understand
neuroplasticity then you can make the
worst times in your life the start of
the best time in your life and that's
what I love about neuroplasticity that
is such ability to change to grow to
regulate your emotions which I know
you're really into and and build
resilience I mean an example of
neuroplasticity that I would share with
with you with our listeners is
gratitude lists
so for years in my journaling I would
write 10 things I'm grateful for every
day
and they were always external things
friends family travel you know
um Financial Freedom whatever
and I literally just got bored of
writing the same things so I thought
okay what what else could I write so I
started writing things like my
creativity my vulnerability my
resilience internal things and that was
a real game changer really what happened
when you started doing that it made me
think that whatever life throws at me
I've got the tools and resources within
me to deal with it
um and and I didn't always have you know
in my 20s
I wouldn't say I was very emotionally
regulated
but
learning that
whatever happens the sort of
the pendulum swing for your emotions the
higher it goes the lower it goes as well
and and bringing that to like parameters
that you're comfortable with is
that gives you sort of autonomy and
agency in life sure
um
and and again that's the thing I love
about neuroplasticity rule number three
is be adaptive with Dean graziosi what
environment are you surrounding yourself
with and who are you listening to right
what environment who are you listening
to if you come over here do you have
negativity in your life are you learning
from the right people if not you have to
add those because that's part of your
bridge to get from where you are to
where you want to be do you have a new
business plan a plan to make the money
you want the the flow if it's the old
one that one's not working your best
thinking got you here you need Next
Level thinking so do you need to add to
bridge that Gap let's let's go back over
here principle number two innovation
and adapt quickly Peter Drucker said
Innovation marketing are the only two
things when it comes to business the
rest are all expenses
right so innovation
adapting is the most important thing to
where you want to go you know Wayne
Gretzky said something great when he was
asked why he was such a great hockey
player anybody know what Wayne Gretzky
said why he was so good at hockey he was
one of the greatest hockey players of
all time for those who don't follow
hockey I'm not a big I don't follow
hockey but I love seeing the greats most
some people skate to where the puck was
most people skate to where the puck is I
found a way to skate to where the puck
is going if you are not in an Innovative
state if you're not learning to adapt
and shift when something like a variant
that was announced four days ago can
have shut down the country again you got
to realize we are in a new world if
you're doing things the way you used to
do and you're not ready to shift and
adapt then you're already losing out
you're already losing ground
and think about it
I don't know about you but when my
confidence is down
when I'm watching the news when I'm
seeing the world shift when your
confidence is down it is hard to think
about pivoting correct it's hard to
think about adapting correct it's hard
to get in Flow State and be Innovative
so we need to keep ourselves around
people who are innovating who have
already innovated before who continue to
innovate who can adapt and adjust pivot
and keep moving forward because if
you're howling around people that say
hey we're just going to wait to see how
things go think about that
you know think about the book who moves
my cheese
right everybody on the concept of who
Moved My Cheese right A Couple Of Mice
the cheese coming every day they're
loving it all of a sudden the cheese
stops one mouse goes hell I'm gonna wait
right here until they bring me my cheese
back and the other one's like I don't
think so I'm getting a little hungry I'm
gonna go look for some cheese uh you're
crazy just stay right here and wait what
happened to the the the the mouse that
waited he starved to death the other one
had to go down a couple tunnels probably
get lost figure stuff out eventually
found more cheese this is a time do not
wait for your cheese to come back you
must go out and find new cheese you know
when they say when one door closes
another one opens it sounds so magical
like oh it's locked let me go through
this next door no you usually grab the
handle and go ah let me back in please
let me in right
but do you really want what's behind
your old door
think about that question
do you really want what's behind your
old door
you're here today
because you want to go through the next
tour you want another level impact more
do more be more
I'd love for you to think about that
innovation
adapting
if you're not where the puck is going
then you're just doing what everybody
else does
and how many people do you think are
trying to do this on their own also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is rewire your
beliefs about wealth with Marissa peer
and one of the rules of the mind and
it's the best rule is that every thought
you think and every word you say forms a
blueprint and your mind must work to
make that that blueprint reel So when
you say I can't remember anything
I'd lose the eyes in the back of my head
if they weren't fixed in there because I
just can't remember anything in your
mind because that's a blueprint let me
take you to it and when you say my
memory is phenomenal for in fact I'm
like human Google when I read an exam
the minute I read the question my mind
has already gone to work found the
answer and I it stays in my head right
through until I write it on the paper
then I read the next question the same
thing happens as I read the question
Google says here's the answer I work
with children all the time with exam
stress and they come in I was a little
boy last year who had um
I think there were 17 children applied
for every place in his school and he
flunked the mocks and I'm like darling
you're supposed to flunk them all
because it's great to flunk the mocks
you know what mocks are don't you oh is
there in England when you're taking an
exam you have a mock exam maybe six
weeks before you take the exam just to
see how you do and then they say well
you did terribly you did really well and
because you did really well you're going
to pass that exam and because you did
terribly you're going to fail in fact
the ones who do well in the mocks get so
complacent they often don't do so well
in the actual exam and the ones who do
badly think wow I need to up my game I
need to revise more and study more so
when he came in and said my mummy was so
upset because I got really bad marks in
the marks of it that's fantastic
what were you worth and he said that the
the this writing what did you do is I
didn't read the instructions correctly
and I didn't use the right words that's
fantastic and so I said that's fantastic
so what did you need to do and just by
changing his language I didn't use the
right words and explained to him that he
could do it and telling him that his
mind was like Google
then I was asking him some questions
about Harry Potter and I said how do you
know these answers have you studied
everybody went no I just really like it
I said well see how clever your mind is
so when you're working with a kid that
says I don't know awesome about James
Bond ask them about something that they
like and go how do you know this I don't
know how do you know wow you're so smart
because when they like something they
remember and part of school is liking
something so with this little kid he got
into that school I knew he'd get in
because he came in like that and he left
like that he was like I'm gonna nail
this I know what to do my mind is like
Google and I will say to all my clients
whether they're a seven-year-old taking
exam or someone taking a medical exam or
the bar I say whatever you're reading
your focus Narrows down you say the word
narrow down and when you say narrow down
every everything Fades where you're
absorbed in that paper you have
phenomenal powers of concentration
comprehension recall retention and
assimilation and I I say words that help
you the next one comprehension
comprehension retention recall
assimilation I say it over and over
again because the mind believes what you
tell it rule number five is experiment
and examine with Rhonda Byrne from
Slovenia
I've read The Greatest Secret I have to
say it helped me tremendously on my
spiritual journey I'm feeling really
good I'm trying to manifest something
but there's one thing that keeps
repeating in my head
um I've heard and I also know people who
without a doubt knew that they were
going to manifest something but in the
end it didn't happen
um one of my friends knew for certain
that she was going to get a certain job
but at the end she didn't get it in the
book it says if you know that something
is yours it has to manifest so why did
these people not manifest their desires
okay
The Law of Attraction
which governs our mind never makes a
mistake
ever
it's a law and it's infallible
so for example it's the same as the law
of gravity so imagine that as a sidewalk
and people walking down a sidewalk all
of those people are being held to the
sidewalk by the law of gravity you don't
see a couple of people just float off
into the air and think oh the lower
gravity stop working for them you know
they're just like floating off there
goes a few more off they go no everybody
the law of gravity is holding everybody
all of the time and so it is the same
from Law of Attraction
um it the Law of Attraction just doesn't
slip up and so if it didn't manifest
even though the person thought
they felt that they knew they were going
to get it the Law of Attraction did not
receive it in that way the Law of
Attraction received that they that the
that they didn't get it
it's the way it is so so I think it
helps a lot if somebody is I was so sure
I was so sure then you get to examine
the way that you felt and because
believe me I experimented with
everything I would see that something
didn't manifest and then I would see
something else manifested really easily
and so I would think back to what was
the feeling that I had when that other
thing manifested so easily rule number
six is be in the present moment with
Eckhart Tolle when you visualize a goal
that you want to achieve it's not in the
future if if you this is to do with
manifesting
when you want to manifest something
it doesn't work very well when you think
I I I will be famous I need to be famous
I want to be famous not good for
manifestation
uh if you want to manifest something you
have to start with the foundation for
manifestation is always the present
moment it's never it's not the future
what it works very simply Jesus
explained it in one sentence
just one sentence whenever you pray for
something
uh believe that you have received it and
it will be given to you
now the key is that he did not say
believe that you will receive it
because that puts it into the future he
said when you pray for something in
other words when you want something
believe that you have received it now
what does that mean
you have to feel
In This Moment the fullness of life that
is there when you go deep enough into
the being of you then you feel there's
the fullness of life and you feel
there is a sense of Joyful aliveness
that is a sense of power in you that you
sense it that is the presence in you is
there is a power in that presence and
that power is
there's a something that you could solve
almost there's a fullness in it already
you can't really once you contact you
when you're in touch with the the
presence
everything else that you could achieve
in this life I compared I have this
comparison analogy or whatever it is
uh that which you realize within you
this the power
is the cream
and everything else that you could
achieve in this world is the skimmed
milk angle number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
find your what and how with David
Meltzer this is a question I was very
intrigued to ask so
the secret the book The Secret is very
much about manifestation Law of
Attraction what is your
definition of manifestation and how can
somebody take something from a thought
to a reality manifestation to me uh is
the materialization of an idea
and so that leads to the second part of
your question how are ideas materialized
well first you have to think of what you
want right you have to imagine it the
minute you imagine something you think
about what you want
uh you've accessed it it now is a
possibility
where do you think that comes from you
know oh my God a creature you know a
half bunny rabbit half Pug and half
dinosaur
boom I know I just described it to you
it's actually a form of manifestation
it's a possibility it's a possibility
three halves of three different animals
thou other people can put man-made or
pragmatic rules onto that that are
arbitrary and capricious but it exists
it exists I can draw it right right I
can create a cartoon about it right I
can you know make billion dollars in a
movie from it
whatever you want to call it I give it a
name Steve right my half bunny half Pug
and half dinosaur three halves really
weird but
that possibility now through inspiration
through intent the manifestation Pro
process of materialization can take it
far beyond just the possibility of
materialization or manifestation
inspiration intent will take it to a
probability right right when we're
inspired my half dog half Pug half bunny
and half dinosaur if I become inspired
to go ahead and write a movie script and
all that now it's a probability I got a
treatment I got a movie maybe I got a
pilot you know who knows I got a cartoon
book I got toys
whoa whoa whoa you got all that stuff
maybe it's in a video game
what's the difference between that
probability and my perspective
my perspective is already real
right it's just me the how to get in my
own way to to materialize it for other
people to have the same perception so
our perception creates reality every day
that's the the
conflictual idea of what people don't
understand is that if I'm concerned
about mine right first then I can share
it the problem is we're trying to share
other people's perception
instead of worried about our own
projection of perception of the half
dinosaur half Pug and have funny well we
all have a different image of that right
now when you describe it
so where I think people get choked up is
they don't have the skills yet
to actually manifest it into the
physical reality so how do you know what
skills you need to develop when you
don't have the awareness of what skills
you need to develop like let's say you
didn't know how to draw
you've got to take time out of the
equation and ask for help
right right you have to ask oh do you
know that could help me I'm trying to
draw a half dog a half Pug half bunny
and a half dinosaur
you really can help me oh my gosh I knew
so and so or I know drawing or have you
looked at this book where the drawing
and now more materialization more
refined perspective more possibility to
probability to perspective that's why
what and how are so important everyone's
why is the same right we want to help
something or someone
we just use that to truly interfere with
the fact that we don't know how which
really says I know how to do every
single thing and because of the internet
now it's easier but I know how to do
every single thing
I give me anything I'll tell you how I
can get it done you'll pick anything you
want me to tell you how to get to Mars
no problem I'll call Mike massimino you
know at NASA yeah someone who's done it
yeah or knows right
right and if you if nobody knows then
get a group of people that have the most
skill set that can enable it to happen
so that we all together can figure it
out why don't more people ask do you
think in your opinion ego fear we we
don't love ourselves so we immediately
we put conditions and judgments on other
people's perception of us
right and we do it all the time there's
so many times that I say things to my
wife with really good intent and she
takes it the wrong way
nothing I can do about that
that's the the whole problem we're
afraid right someone's gonna say oh
that's stupid or I can't help you that's
not you're just cutting yourself off
from allowing someone to experience the
greatest pleasure in life which is to
help somebody so you start thinking
about when I ask for help I'm giving a
blessing to that person
so if you take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern right so you can take
um uh the idea of eating your favorite
dessert what do you think is happening
in your brain when you pretend you're
eating that favorite dessert of yours
and your mouth starts to water and you
start to feel oh that's such a great
dessert that's neurons in your brain
firing in the neurochemistry that is
associated with that memory firing now
let's say
that you have a disempowering pattern of
being embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed but instead of just thinking
about the pattern oh I don't like it as
soon as you think about the pattern and
it has a I'm going to say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
Center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat's going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less uh uh deeply I mean more
shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if instead of allowing that to
continue you just stopped
and you had this intention
I'm going to dissolve the effectiveness
or the strength of this pattern how do
you do that well first and foremost you
stop you sit and you start with inner
size number one that I actually guide
you through in the book
all right and inner size number one
is called take six calm the circuits so
you want to move from your stress and
react system
to your relax and response system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times in 10 second rhythmic
breaths
and you focus on the air that you're
blowing out through your mouth like
you're blowing out through a straw that
simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually deactivates the
stress fear embarrassment shame guilt
circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense stressful State
you're actually reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level let me
explain what happens so this really
interesting concept called ghosts in the
nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and Mom or Dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on May 17
1972 but your nervous system remembers
what it's like so fast forward You're
Now 51 years old
and you walk in the house and there's a
mess everywhere and even though you have
said I'm not going to bulldoze and yell
at anybody
my body recognizes the situation so what
do you do you repeat the pattern you saw
and so what I'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
I was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now
um trying to create a video and I'm like
doing take after take because I want to
get it right and my daughter comes
Waltzing into the room and was like how
long are you gonna be doing this
and I was like you can't do that
you said I literally like screamed at
her and she looked at me Louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how old's
your daughter
20. and I said I I calmly said you're
right I do
when I get interrupted
I lose control of the response and I'm
working so hard and the way that you and
I'm clearly not mastering this yet but
the way that you do it is as you feel it
rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath you
can notice the pattern and you've got to
create a pause between the emotion
rising up and the reaction that gets
automated and for many people the
reaction Lewis is to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you hate being erupted by
anything this is a great interview I did
like I didn't do it I didn't do the
bulldoze I was I was calm because I
wasn't a human being I'm only mean to
human beings
um I know like I a lot of people run
away they avoid conflict they say it's
just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict continues to create a pattern
where you feel invisible and your
boundaries are tromped on that's a
pattern and you know here's the other
thing about patterns running away and
being quiet might have saved you when
you were little because if you were
quiet and out of the room you didn't get
hit you didn't get yelled at you were
out of Harm's Way so when you were
little it was a genius pattern because
it protected you but the issue for
adults is that again we walk around with
the patterns that we created when we
were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are completely a robot to these patterns
the voice within us that believes that
we are not allowed to be happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am I to feel good
who am I to feel great who am I to be
happy that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with covid when we witness
people suffering we think well how dare
I be happy I would say to you how dare
you not be happy it's your happiness
it's the collective happiness it's the
group Collective happiness that raises
the energetic frequency of the world if
we those of us who have moments of
happiness and Grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion has momentum it has
power it elevates our children it
elevates our family member it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your Divine Duty here on
Earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good I want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you who are you not to feel good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me we are more
comfortable being uncomfortable than we
are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for you ever
noticed that some people seem to want to
hang on to stuff that is bothering them
they're forever talking about it they
don't want to let it go they've had a a
failure at something in his drone they
can't get over it they just can't get
over it or somebody said something nasty
to them they don't want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
foreign
anything in your life that's not serving
you that's not causing you to grow
that's not adding to the quality of your
life
I don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows the only thing that can
grow is the thing you give energy to why
would you hold on to anything that's not
serving you now I want you to think
about this I'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because I don't
think I have to I just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you you're
making a terrible error it's going to
cause all kinds of problems you may
blame other people or other things you
may blame the situation
it's you are the cause of the problem
demanded
told me to pick up this book and read it
Ray Stanford he had a saying he used to
say to me Bob you're the only problem
you'll ever have and you're the only
solution
I think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but I do
understand it
and you know something
I am the only problem I'll ever have and
I Am the Only Solution don't hold on to
anything that is not serving you
rejected if you know the beautiful part
about having an inductive reasoning
Factor that's the part that chooses
thoughts you can accept or reject the
beautiful part of your mind you can
accept or reject anything that comes
into your world except to reject it it's
a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you I think one of my first
things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an was
animated response saying your
application will not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had me right
so that's the first thing the first step
is don't take all fear failure I'll give
an example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast
which they know all the time we're
saying all the time but if I don't hear
a no from the guest directly that's not
a no like someone's team can say no
someone's assistant can say no someone's
PR team can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah with the results you
want the results you want and don't make
that result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah and I think a lot of people can do
that in life but we're so afraid to like
go on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
I spend a lot of time thinking about
this
at the times it almost drives me crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
it then the bud Chrome and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside in my studio
I'm sitting here in my desk and
the cameras around me but out there is
that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder why the tide goes
way out the tide comes way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same upper on Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up in the air and it comes way down
very high very low tide now some place
the Tide's not very big they do have a
tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you ever think about this do
you know that everything in this
universe happens in an exact way
and exactly not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States acted as Dr Warner Von
Braun who was the master mind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to Earth Ron Brown answered him
in five words the will to do it that's
it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but you didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
Von Braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can time the
landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
now he said these lives must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law
now we do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
manchanged and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
book uh that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like what are the laws and
then study them
you know when you have no idea what
you're capable of you have no idea you
have no idea the person you could be the
things you could accomplish the things
you can do the people you can serve you
have no idea that's why I don't like
10-year goals 10-year goals think about
who you used to be 10 years ago you know
could that person accurately with any
with any degree of certainty predict
where you could be right now now like if
you're growing and you're learning
you're improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of
career you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do well I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows I question
everything I want to I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because your biggest problem is you
don't know what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no no
that's not going to work for me you know
even boom got a B I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I end up doing is making a
new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so when creating a new plan
then I have certainty in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe it anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be downward spiral like if
I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working and I can't come with a new
plan then I don't know what to do with
my life and that would create a downward
spiral I've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places
and so the way that I come out of it is
just say great things will happen to me
great things happen to me they already
they always happen to me great things
happen to me and I'll figure this out
and that gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
the way things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year old great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for more
advice on how to manifest properly check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you understood
that you could dissociate all of your
attention from this three-dimensional
reality and have no attention on
anything known and understand it's the
field that creates matter that matter
that emits the field and if you could
get to that place